ja sind dann gehe ich zu lange wie die
lage sein muss natürlich ziel ist es
wirklich schön wenn man gerade neues
album rausbringt videos gedreht haben
sind auf youtube extrem erfolgreich auf
der startseite gelandet ist es
wahrscheinlich also im aufbau natürlich
nicht drehen leute mobilisieren das
organisieren das organisieren mit
manager strecken mit dem streiten kopf
ikone ende natürlich aber letztendlich
hat sich das gelohnt ich habe ja noch
ein bisschen was vor mir ich muss noch
ein zwei videos drehen
aber muss man durch und man das machen
möchte
das besondere an dir ist ja dass du
wirklich im wahrsten sinne des wortes
ein gangster rapper bist da gibt es sehr
wenige von du warst in der jva siegburg
und anderen unter anderem die berühmt
berüchtigt leider ist da gab es tote
tote was ja schrecklich ist aber du bist
andererseits auch einer der dann islam
formuliert war so total integriert
worden ist ich sage es gab ein
schauspiel stück über dich also jemand
agenturszene integriert ist das bei dir
wirklich durch den gefängnisaufenthalt
so eine 180 grad wendung gewesen oder
wie war das bei mir sagen ich war ja
nicht nur ein ich war öfter wir finden
uns auf jeden fall und wir haben unsere
sachen bildung einer kriminellen
vereinigung das ist schon das ist es
bremst das ist auf jeden fall ein dickes
brett gewesen natürlich der staatsanwalt
musste sehr lange
die anklageschrift verlesen das war
erheblich wie soll ich sagen war auf der
schaden auf jeden fall erheblich und der
richter aber alle natürlich kennst du
doch was ist diesen jugendlichen ohne
kriminelle energie das war für die
sofort klar da muss man wegsperren und
so natürlich auch paar kleinere chancen
war davor paar mal in u-haft und wo und
irgendwann muss ich halt ins gefängnis
und jetzt aber egal das ist anderes
thema weil ich sagen wollte deswegen was
du gerade gefragt ist das hat nicht das
gefängnis aus mir gemacht und ich wollte
selber was ändern so also europa
wo du gesagt hab ich was ändern der
moment kam wo ich gemerkt habe dass ich
ein bisschen filmen wurde
er ist ein bekannter wurde schreiben
gefängnis und zu der zeit ging seine
frischen angesagt und da kam ich auch
einiges energy ag frt fries in angie
genau das war das war das erste ding in
deutschland was jemals mit ihm zu tun
hatte weil es war 2007 26 denn wer war
in deutschland überhaupt anerkannt der
knast gab es nicht also über knapp
geredet da man sich schon am zittern ist
ja nicht wie heute ist es so ich hab das
auf jeden fall den trieren gesetz für
sowas unbewusst welche das ist ja alles
realität gewesen so und danach wohl ein
bisschen fame ich kann mit zeitungen
plötzlich weil diverse web habe mich
natürlich ein bisschen gepusht haben so
bis dato noch gar keine musik eigentlich
so richtig gemacht und dann irgendwann
wurde ich vom habe ich mir so gedacht
das kann was werden warum nicht bleibe
ich am ball einfach ja und dann habe ich
einfach gemacht und jetzt bin ich wieder
vorher entlassen oder ja nicht so lange
so wie man denkt aber ich würde auf
jeden fall sind das zwei drittel also
fast jeder insasse bekommt zwei drittel
auf gute führung trotters wird ihr
angerechnet oder halt eine u haft wird
die angerechnet und dann zieht man das
von der straße ab da kannst du ein
bisschen früher rausgehen ist jetzt
nicht die welt halb strafe natürlich
besser gewesen dass ich mal die hälfte
schlauesten leider nicht bei jedem der
verband ein bisschen zu heftig war zu
heftig für die weil ich weiss noch genau
ich war drinnen und zum beispiel für
dieses projekt für dieses film sache zum
beispiel da musste ich auf jeden fall
eingeloggt hat der häftling sei aber ich
war natürlich habe ich nicht gelockert
offener vollzug aber im knast noch das
heißt offener vollzug ist nicht so mein
erstes ziel das haus gehen darf aber man
durfte beantragen dann auch gut dass
dann abgecheckt ob es also noch luft für
drei stunden
da muss ich mich melden wenn nicht warum
jagen muss vor lange kämpfen dass
erstmal diesen drei stunden kriege die
wollten mich kein urlaub geben die
wollen wir nichts geben sobald die sagen
kriminelle ader psychologen im knast
roten zu den ideen ist ja ihr habt mit
eigenen aber jede gruppe hat immer eine
psychologin noch voll die [ __ ] tochter
die er wirklich so hart gekämpft dass
ich nichts machen darf zum beispiel
juliane klein wir haben einen knacks
fußball gespielt
ein knast mannschaft und wir wurden sehr
schnell voll berüchtigt weil jedes spiel
auf einmal gewonnen haben und shoppen
gehen spiele 34 tore mache ich war ein
guter fußballer so war gut ich konnte
auf ein bisschen
und irgendwann kam der mannschaft von
draußen - gespielt und ich habe sie so
fertig gemacht die wollten mich
unbedingt haben wollten wir damals ein
projekt starten das ich als häftling
weil ihr die mannschaft war nicht weit
vom knast entfernt war so halbe stunde
so irgend so eine orts mannschaft so und
die wollten mich unbedingt haben wollte
mich auch bezahlen und wirklich richtig
krass dinge wollen wir machen alle und
zu der zeit war es ja er hat ja wie
gesagt dass diese leute gestorbenen
gefängnis und der ruf vom cluster
sowieso voll im arsch so gefängnis
keiner kümmert sich um häftlinge so
richtig klar ist dass da so schlimm
musikbox so schlimm ist das wie man sich
das in heftigen knall
was ist da ist dass hinter den türen
marketing das gar nicht mit das
beantworte ich dir gleich ob hotel
fahren so recht kein problem ist dann
klappt das muss mein verlangen die knast
leitung auf jeden fall die haben das
voll begrüßt jammern wir machen den ruf
im knast wieder ge spiel machen unser
mache den namen von sico wieder hoch
dann kam ich von vielen zeitungen wegen
anderen langlauf jo kelly war bei uns
aber unser langlauftrainer ich war 23
mal auf wählte er dann gegen diese
langlauf sache aber auf jeden fall da
die schläge merkt an dass sie nach
medientyp im mini kameras in klasse 10 a
100 sohn soll geht mal zu dem ok dafür
ist mit dem lassen mit denen hatte ich
ein bisschen nach in freiheit so es
kommt ein bisschen auf putz zu hauen
karriere im gefängnis gewesen deswegen
genauer auf ihre wahl knast hat das so
voll die waren voll dafür dass ich das
mache meinen sport beamte der wache ich
coole sau
vor allem ihr potenzial gesehen hat auch
immer mich gepusht wenn es um sport ging
aber dann kam die psychologin natürlich
im spiel nähe der darf da nicht raus wir
dürfen so was nicht sofort der ist ein
häftling der muss drin bleiben der darf
nicht urlaub gehen darf nicht fußball
spielen draußen
die hatten diese uhren tochter hoffe
dass die mittlerweile tot ist weil die
wald wollte es uhren tochter
wahrscheinlich tochter meine ich doch
also falls das nicht bringen das piep
das einfach
soll auf jeden fall das ist halt so ein
bisschen so bei hinter geschichten so
hinter der ganzen sache
und was viele natürlich nicht wissen nur
die insider so zu der anderen frage was
du meinst aber so hart da drin ist
natürlich ist gefängnis gefängnis also
dass viele in deutschland denken er ist
in deutschland ja da geh' mal da rein
sei mal für zwei stunden gesperrt dann
guck mal wie du dich fühlst sachen
ursachen wie man sich fühlt sich einfach
nur weil halt ist nicht jeden tag ein um
bringt ja wenn du jeden wenn jeder
[ __ ] eine kleinigkeit wird in amerika
je nachdem welche bundesstaat das ist 20
jahre kriegsjahre bringen wir auch leute
um das ist eine strafe ob die jetzt noch
fünf jahre hoch jedoch nicht bekommst du
sowieso nicht mehr aus von daher so ist
die atmosphäre dort atmosphäre knast
atmosphäre treffen die falschen leute
fresse bist du findest du jemanden
finden die dich mach du das machen ist
alles knast hier ist genau wie knast
dort nun nicht halten mit dem brutalen
ich bringe ein um und bleibt aber auch
hier in deutsch kann es passieren viele
sachen die natürlich in den medien nicht
gezeigt werden daher deutschland noch so
ein land ist wo die sowas nicht direkt
pushen möchten aber dass mit siegburg
oder eine gestorben ist diese arme junge
tut mir so leid möglich da habe ich
gleich darüber reden er kam aus essen
ich kannte ihn ist nicht so gut hatte
mit ihm nichts zu tun aber wir haben uns
schon partner getroffen gehabt
ich hab' ich habe ihn vorher war ich
kann mich nicht mehr ist schon so lange
her aber man kannte sich so und schafft
es auch nicht den besten draht zu dem
aber deshalb ein junge gewesen ganz
normaler typischer der eigentlich mit
knast gar nichts zu tun haben dürfte die
haben den rein gesteckt ich weiß habe
ich mir genau warum ich glaub wegen
schwarzfahren regen rechnung nicht
gezahlt
und da war ja noch ein anderer typ der
sich auch noch erhöhen hat der hat mich
sogar noch einen tag vorher nach
zigaretten gefragt ich gehe am nächsten
morgen zur arbeit mal hängt er da blaue
zunge
es ist ein anblick der prägt ein
das ist eigentlich nicht auch ohne
kinder seiner stirn mode so ist man
gestern noch geredet heute betont dass
harte sachen und was soll ich sagen
die cluster ob hier oder dort jeder
fühlt dasselbe ist das denn was gutes
nein auf gar keinen fall also das ist
nicht das was ich auf die ich sag mal
gerade spur wieder
also von der schiefen bahn in die spur
gebracht hat ich kann ja so nicht sagen
aber ich weiß nur dass ich durch die
ganzen sachen medien mäßig ist dass mir
gedacht habe
lasst mich das erst mal machen ich weiß
noch genau ich gedacht habe ich habe
gedacht dass mich das erste mal machen
gucken wie erfolgreich sind kriminell
sein kann ich danach immer noch da ist
immer hier ist hier drin ist kann man
das legt man ja wie legt man nicht
abnehmen obwohl man weiß dass es
letztlich ein ich hab schon an brände
ich habe schon ich habe schon fast
anderen der sv bekommen da schon
lebenslänglich wenn du intensivtäter
müssen
das ist schon praktisch will machen so
damit drohen die schon neu regeln und
dann noch bei mir intensivtäter gab
schon richtig drauf eingehen aber dass
eine harte sache das heißt man muss
aufpassen so einer wie ich zb wenn ich
mich ändern dann muss ich mich ändern
wenn nicht irgendwann geschrieben und
komme ich nicht mehr raus weil lebens
gefängnis reinkommt ist leicht nur
rauskommen ist das schwieriger äußerung
ist verbrechen so was wie so sucht ja
wenn du von klein auf verbrecher bis ich
meine andere wollten polizisten werden
andere und feuerwehrmann ich muss
verbrecher ich hab ja ich hab mich was
ich wollte ich hatte so ich weiß nicht
ich wollte sportler werden einerseits
aber auch irgendwie hat dieses
verbrechen gegen mich voll angezogen ich
weiß nicht warum ist leider früher so
gewesen ich bin nicht dass ich nicht
stolz drauf oder so aber ich sage halt
not wie es ist so ist es fakt so was
kann ich auch nicht verleugnet das ist
immer ein teil von mir zb besser so ich
höre dir wenn ich nachts nach hause
laufen irgendwo immer die läden an ich
bin voll so immer noch was was was kann
nicht holen
aber ich mache das nicht aber das ist
schwer abzusehen dass der kampf mit mir
selbst was kannst du hier holen die
camps alle seine kämpfe
ein laptop meldung unter sitz versteckt
das ist oder wenn ich essen gehe
ich guck direkt immer fluchtwege falls
mit einer falls etwas passiert ob nicht
legal war ich habe diesen aber bei
vielen leuten so das ist bei leuten die
kriminellen sind oder waren
wir haben immer noch diesen diesem
dieses denken so weiß vielleicht kann
das passieren da muss ich mich aus dem
staub machen
so kann ich am besten weiß dass brown
habe das ist das ist aber auch nicht gut
weil das macht auch sehr paranoid bei
mister so wenn ich abends laufe
und wenn ich nur eine höhere der läuft
ich bin mach meine fäuste direktbanken
werden was passieren könnte ja was
passieren so weißt du und das halt alles
ein bisschen geht auf die typischerweise
das ist nicht cool ist oder sollte aber
das ist das ekelhaft das was du buy die
waffen sind geladen
das ist ja so ein bisschen hier die
waffen geladen ist könnte was passiert
ist dann könnten zum nachfolger des
quasi so ein bisschen in mir drin ist in
sein drittes jahr auf jeden fall aber
natürlich versuche ich das was ich
bisher gemacht habe
also mit der musik mit dem medien und
was auch egal was ich mache
dabei zu bleiben das macht mir auch viel
spaß andere dann lenkt mich auch immer
gut ab weil flash wenn drei vier jahren
nicht klappt dann wird wieder kriminell
und die kids da draußen ich mal ab und
sagte mir dann so nehmt euch ein
beispiel alter die zur schule macht euer
ding besser so mehr
also kann man in ruhe schlafen auf jeden
fall wenn man kennt die szene wie wird
man kann man alt werden als verbrecher
kann man 80 90 jahren werden kann man
nicht werden schweren was wie hoch ist
die lebenserwartung als verbrecher also
ich sag mal kriminalfall also ich rede
jetzt also ich rede vom vom dem sachen
vielleicht wo ich die die ich gemacht
habe oder in den kreis noch die ich
komme da war ja nicht verbrecher seine
jeanshose klagen
dann ging es richtig mitgliedschaft da
ging es richtig um drogen ging es sich
um einen überfall wo leute wie du
richtig packen muss sie ist eine ganz
andere sachen soll und in dem milieu
willst du keine 40 wenn du nicht
aufpasst damit du keine 30
passt ein markantes töten soll er immer
besser sei es egal aber eine klingel
reicht trifft er dich bist du tust du
musst aufpassen und du bist ja auch
immer man ihn selber total vorsieht es
kann auch einfach er was passieren weil
man ja immer in hab acht stellung ist
hier vielleicht hast du irgendein
abgezogen sagen wir mal dass tim
vielleicht was abgezogen ja und er will
rache zum beispiel der kommt nicht nach
einem tag für schon nach einem jahr habe
ich ja du erwartest das gar nicht denn
wir schießen die auf dich und hier
prügeln die dann raus treten auf dich
vielleicht trifft da nicht vielleicht
kann alles passieren
deswegen muss man das ist ein milieu das
was gefährlich ist
das ist nicht zu spaßen ist auch nichts
zum angeben und das macht auch keinen
das macht auch keiner denn diese diesem
milieu tätig ist ja sag ich jetzt mal
ganz klar das ergibt nicht an der sache
nicht
genau das ist keiner der fans vor allem
im handy
da sowieso nicht so ist das sind keine
leute die versuchen zu sein
er soll einfach leute die diese
hemmschwelle verloren haben und welche
leute zu bedrohen oder sonst irgendwas
einfach die indizes an das nicht kennen
die einfach nur geld machen wollen die
einfach gangster sind alte das wort
gangster wird ist ja in deutschland
schon ein bisschen ausgelutscht weil die
leute denken gangster kollege clown
möchtegern gangster selbst von mir alter
ich habe schon mitbekommen wie leute
möchte nur weil er denkt es beim knast
einen gangster nein das denke ich nicht
er hat da nicht so weil ich habe das
gemacht für das was ich für nötig
gehalten habe um leistung um meine
taschen voll zu kriegen
das habe ich nicht gemacht und meinem
nachbar oder irgendjemanden zu sagen hey
komm hol ich bin noch nie gemacht und
diese ganzen sachen zum beispiel im
knast mit filmen lassen oder über
darüber zu retten was ich jetzt mache
jetzt kann ich machen weil ich meine
strafe erstens hab ich die abgesessen
jetzt mache ich das nicht mehr und das
ist auch kein geheimnis mehr
das heißt dann darüber öffentlich reden
ohne dass man sagt wir reden über diese
sachen aber macht das noch nicht macht
das nicht mehr
wie ist der dass gesprochen von der
hemmschwelle die man überwindet hast du
dir hast du nie wieder diese
hemmschwelle oder was also jetzt darf
man ab wenn du eine zeit lang nichts
mehr machst kriegst du immer noch dieses
kriegs hast du diese hemmschwelle so ein
bisschen wieder weil dann denkst soll
ich mich nicht früher gab es diese frage
dich soll ich wo ich wusste da ist was
dann hole ich mir das
längere zeit nichts mehr macht und auch
mit vielen leuten die in diesem milieu
tätig sind nicht mehr viel zu tun als
man dann dann spaltet du dich sofort ein
bisschen auch ab und dann ist auch gut
dann bist du weg davon so ein bisschen
aber wie gesagt er die gedanken und
natürlich nur leicht ist das nicht die
abzulegen
aber es ist trotzdem noch so ist es
besser als wenn du das direkt machen
würdest du es lieber denkt lieber ein
bisschen eine kleine ahnung aber ich
weiß nicht kann ich nicht so gut
erklären
vielleicht bringt das nicht vorüber ich
weiß da stehst und hersteller schon
also ich stelle es mir so vor dass wenn
du wieder ins falsche milieu kommt dass
auch kämpfen kann
mit mir kann kippen auf jeden fall man
bis heute noch ein bisschen wie die
sucht halt das adrenalin dieser klo
dieses dieses ding ich hole mir was mir
zusteht so weit ist und weil es ist auch
ein bisschen die systemfrage so wenn du
siehst wie die leute behandelt werden
vom staat und alles das faktisch auch am
mutter holt zuhause stress kein geld so
dass in sachen die mich antreiben dann
zum beispiel solche sachen zu beginn
wenn du wenn du siehst dass man die
miete nicht zahlen kann dass man kein
essen auf tisch hat ja was wir zu machen
vermisst du das geld natürlich von der
menge wird vermisst das geld ist er ist
ja schließlich hat wo das geld herkommen
aber irgendwann muss das geld ja an sich
mal in folge ist es einfach zu wissen
ich bin eine fremde stadt zum beispiel
kein problem darstellt aktien ruin
ich kann ohne probleme was essen gehen
aber nur eine fremde stadt zum beispiel
bis auf welchen umständen auch immer was
kein geld auf der tasche da stehst du
luft da dann bist du verloren
früher immer geld auf tasche immer geld
gepumpt hat egal wie die probleme dort
ist bewusst verkauf die probleme ab geld
dann geld ist bester freund wenn du geld
hast
geld stinkt nicht geld ist immer hier
dann macht man einfach bis man
irgendwann durch verrat vom essen weil
die cloud das geld immer ich hab immer
was vernünftig gegessen ja aber
nachhaltig bauchschmerzen entweder oder
eine neue hose gekauft hat ist kaputt
ein schlechtes karma verstehst du wenn
du mit menschen was böses tut kommt auf
dich zurück irgendwann ob es jetzt eine
hohe dosis die dann zerreißt weiß wie
oft welche löcher in der rosa wir
wirklich nichts gerissen
das glaube ich noch nie so eine alte
rose von früher also die von gerichten
kammer zum schlechten kammer noch zeigen
aber dass mein lieblingshose bin ich
nicht nur leistung passiert einfach für
manche leute will mich ist verfolgt
hatten die leute die jetzt wieder die
das wissen so die das auch gemacht aber
die wissen was ich meine ist das wird
nicht so ich schau dir ich ich ich weiß
rechnet macht schlechtes karma er ohne
scheiß wenn du anderen menschen was
böses tut alter dann hast du auch mal
sagen wir mal ich zocke ich ab ich muss
dich fesseln schweiß aus 20.000 zu hause
ich komme ich nimm deine 20 mit ich ja
meist danach gehe ich raus spiel
lottogewinn noch 100.000 euro zum glück
habe ich da nicht mehr raus wer vom auto
überfahren hatte und stets an eine
dummheit wo man sagt egal was aber noch
nicht so oder umfeld passiert du bist
ein bein
keine ahnung es kommt immer auf dich
zurück also verbrechen lohnt sich nicht
so recht keiner weise verbrechen lohnt
sich aber das musst du mir nicht sagen
sagt dass man den politikern die machen
nämlich richtig business die machen noch
mehr business als ich und als jeder
andere auch alter und verbrechen lohnt
sich wer vielleicht auch mal albumtitel
verbrechen lohnt sich nicht
ja wer auf jeden fall mein album titel
aber ich glaube das wird die
jugendlichen natürlich nicht so einfach
nicht hören wollen die wollen denn die
wollen wir wollen den gangsta rappern
die wollen auch was du früher gemacht
hast und das gibt sie ihnen das geben
was macht ihr spaß also darüber so was
tut man es macht spaß auch eine art von
selbsttherapie alter so natürlich mache
auch nicht nur ich mache ja nicht nur so
haut drauf raps machte auch die peh
sachen ich mache auch nachdenkliche
sache natürlich gehen die dann halt
neben dem anderen ein bisschen unter
weil die mehrheit will halt das aber ich
mache ja dass ich mach ja nicht etwas
was die mehrheit will was wie die leute
wohl ich mache das was ich will ob du
willst auch du willst oder nicht mache
ich das was ich habe lust auf wenn ich
diesen bieter und stellt mir da muss was
die betroffenen etwas besser also jetzt
in linx übrigens unten im video ob du
willst oder nicht das neue album von
synergy vorbestellen de vorbestellen
amazon vorbestellen ob itunes amazon ihr
könnt euch das vorbestellen alter
unterstützen mich gibt euch lösen
weil wenn man vorgestellt dann hat es
auch richtig gute chancen in den charts
nach oben zu gehen
hoffentlich warum nicht ich wünsche dir
glück fehlen das danke dir